The green agenda if pressed in
competently in political terms with the
wrong compelling messages,
uh,
imposed on people in the wrong ways will
actually delay the green revolution.
The,
and we've just had a perfect example
here,
but people are saying,
oh,
we must be very careful about gas
expansion and,
uh,
we've done to shale gas,
America's fine,
but we didn't want to see too much
encouragement here.
What is the net effect of that?
The net effect is that American code is
pouring into Europe.
We're burning more color here in this
country.
Europe's code as a whole is increasing
the actual Germans or planning new coal
fired stations where s and m c o to
welland forming,
falling to America to the 20th,
20 year level,
lowest level,
uh,
and the foreign 14% in the last two
years.
And the per capita emissions has fallen
dramatically.
So it's not just a recession issue.
Well,
I mean,
because you have chosen a quite a two
year horizon in a time of low us grace.
Can I call you on that?
Well,
you can call me,
but the 57 million extra people in
America in the last 20 years,
and yet the carbon co two emissions up
now 20% down,
they are very loud.